this is a production of Cornell
University
so thank you very much
for the invitation for a nice
introduction I'm very happy to be here
actually a first time at Cornell nice
people in a very nice environment so
today I will be talking to you about
growth and what can we learn by about
Ovid organization as its in plans
looking at solar behaviors and quantify
in quantitative manner so one of the
biggest question in developmental
biology is how do we get from a group of
undifferentiated cells can be a million
cells it can be a prime odium into the
variety of different shapes that we see
in nature so how do we get a hand
instead of ear and rhinos here inside
etc etc the genetic basis of development
is sort of relatively well understood so
we know the genes that are involved in
development of the leaf for example the
biggest challenge is to understand how
the action of those genes genes
translate into the biological forms and
this is not trivial question there is no
easy answer for this we have to use
specific tools to do that because genes
are actually acting on different general
process developmental processes so some
genes will influence patterning so for
example the number of fingers of my my
hand
others will influence mug or Grove so
how much they will grow and even other
dreams will be deciding you know okay
how do I would how they differentiate
into different tissue so why they have
skin here and not somewhere else we use
plants for to study development and to
look at growth in in general there are
several reasons for this
so here's our abilities plants plant and
actually first of all plants are
continuously growing organs so basically
you have growth and organizes
continuously however whole life in
animals of course we know that most of
the things happens in the belly of the
mother for example so it's very
difficult to observe this so this is
should I be camera system of Arabidopsis
you from the top three importantly we
have a cell wall sir wall actually makes
the sauce good together so by de Mille
do not move
one in respect to another so
basically we can observe what is the
fate of the cells over time so we know
that that blue cells will give rise to a
specific region later on so we know what
happens to them and thirdly in
especially are the early stages of our
gana Genesis the cell death is sort of
relatively limited factor it's it's not
so important like in animals so animals
if you want to have fingers that are
separated you have specific cell birth
in between them to separate them in
clans it's less important of course this
is a simplification so how do we do that
how do we look at growing plants so we
basically use comfortable microscope to
acquire 3d images like this for example
here should I pick a meristem of tomato
and basically what we look at is the
outlines of the cells that were using
more for graphics software that is was
developed by Richard Smith we are able
now to segment those cells into segments
them and basically find the
correspondence between the two time
points after the organ has grown based
based on this we can compute different
heat maps so for example what we see
here is the basically growth so area
extension of each itself with cells
marked in blue growing slowly and the
cells that grows fast are marked in red
so you can see for example that at least
should have become rarest and I would
now you hit it from the side just that
are giving rise to the leaf primordium
are growing very fast and there will be
next prime rhodium coming up here and
you see already the growth is very high
in this in this area what can we compute
as wells for example the growth an
isotropy so basically we can get
information if the cells growing
extending in one direction or isotropic
in both so for example those cells are
growing here the longer line indicates
you that principal orientation of growth
of these cells so we can do we can use
more for graphics to extract this
information for in a two and a half D we
call it like this because it's a surface
extract quantification but on curved
surface so it's not 3d it's not 2d so to
an healthy let's say
and we can do it as well for free d so
here what you see is a early leaf of
cardamon and you can see the
segmentation of cells at the beginning
after 24 hours in 3d so those are the
mother cells and daughter cells 24 hours
later and we can do it for epidermal
layer we can do it for the l2 so deeper
layers as well to get the information in
3d as well then for the the data that I
will show today will be more mainly on
2d services so the main topic of my talk
today will be looking at growth in
leaves so how what can we learn and how
powerful this technology can be to
understand the development of the leaf
in the inner implant if you go to the
your garden you go outside man maybe not
now but in summer you appreciate that
there's many many different leaf forms
you can have leaves that are very simple
like simple blade leaves and some of
some other lives will be very compound
like in davidic into individual leaflets
so this Magus leaves a very powerful
system to study the diversification of
farms in in plants so what do we know
about the leaf growth until now so
basically most of the information comes
from model species starting from tobacco
in 1933 and in Arabidopsis so what we
know is that we know how what is the
growth globally in the leaf distributed
so we know that for example in
Arabidopsis there will be a basic petal
gradient of growth from the tip to the
base that will restrict growth to the
proximal region of the of the blade so
we know generally how this happens and
we know that this growth rate so to have
you can see here solar cells the
region's growing first are in red again
this growth gradient is correlated with
differentiation of the leaf so the
differentiation of the leaf will also
start at the tip and will progress
slowly over the base so the red cells
here are the pavement cells the fully
differentiated epidermal cells that are
highlighted as a measure of the
differentiation
so we globally know what's going on in
the leaf we also know what happens
locally so the marginal that if the
meleave margin is very important region
for the misshape first to save the first
shaping of the leaf form because all the
protrusions serrations leaflets as a
transit they will emerge from the
meristematic region at the marginal
value so the Indus in this margin will
help to create the diversity and we know
what happens there actually we know that
oxen Harmon plant hormone oxen is very
important for the easy ation of the
protrusions and there is a transcription
factor CAC to for example that will be
important for the repression of growth
around adjacent to those protrusions to
enable them to grow out so locally it's
pretty ok we understand what's going on
at the molecular level we know what's
happening globally the big challenge
that we have faced is is to understand
how those global factors and the local
regulators are integrated and modulated
truly the diversity of organ forms of
leaf forms that we find in nature and
Tudor to answer this question we have
used actually two different species from
brassicas a family so those are the two
species that are very closely related in
evolution they are but they are very
different in leaf forms so are a bit of
siciliana you probably all know and
probably touched it and interpreted in
some way so arab that is a simple leaf
with a tiny serrations at the margin you
can see them here on the proximal part
of belief and the very closely related
species that is very different in
morphologies Academy near suta
so Kappa Mina has actually a leaf
subdivided into individual leaflets so
we have terminal leaflet at the tip of
the leaf and then several pairs of
lateral leaflets that will develop that
are supported by very small aperture so
they are very different
but they come from the same structure so
if you go back in time and look at how
what do they look like when they
initiate you cannot distinguish if this
will be a compound on simple list I will
the tiny leaf primordium at the
beginning of the development will be the
same so we know that to actually
understand what's going on we have to
look in time and look at what happens to
those cells that are here they at the
beginning to give rise to the diversity
to diversity due to those different
forms so we have established at life
imaging protocol to help do it and so
what you will see in those movie movies
basically as I though that the Heat are
the basically the growth of the whole
leaf over one week with cells that are
growing fast were highlighted in red and
cells that are growing slowly are blue
so we can actually now basically monitor
the growth of both species paradoxes and
car demeanor at cellular resolution for
whole leaf in epidermis basically for
all the relevant period of the
development of the leaf so we have a
quantitative information for every
single leaf single cell in this leaf
so if you look at this as a static
images from one day after initiation
till seven days or even eight in a car
demeanor you see the distribution of the
growth yeah and you are looking at this
oh my god this is so complicated and
this was our reaction at the beginning
like what do we do with this you know
how good what can how can we deal with
it the first time so I will try to walk
you through and show you some
interesting features so the first
question would be they are very
different
that is there something that is common
for both so is there any common what's
common for both those are a bit of
seasoned and cardamon a leaf is there
something maybe okay so if you look at
the early stages of development so at
the early prime odium even if they go
the different growth rates this is
faster this is slower the early growth
is homogeneous so there's no specific
red region that is growing very fast and
the other ones go slowly everything is
just
elongating growing homogeneously
everywhere so this is what we notice
there's a first common thing the second
finger you can notice is the basic petal
gradient of growth this is well known in
Arabidopsis you can see that the growth
is restricted first at the tip and this
maintains more at the base of the leaf
and this is well known we wanted to see
it can be seen in Arabi in card amina
actually yes if you look at the graph at
the tip it's actually slowing down
faster but the more proximal regions so
we have the same behavior in the two
species as well here another example the
growth in the midrib petiole region is
rather slower and more anisotropic so
basically this region is extending one
orientation is elongating in both
species and in the graph in the blade
future blade is slightly faster and more
isotropic so the same in both
orientation orientations so what we
concluded out of this is that there must
be some quantity quantity of leaf a
quantitative conservation of Dogra does
go so grow is quantitatively conserved
in between the two species the same
thing visited our gradient of growth
specific graph in the midrib specific
graph in the blade is maintained but
they are very different yeah extremely
different so there must be something
very different to lead to those forms so
what you are looking here now ad is a
rabid abscess region that initiates
aeration so this small protrusion at the
margin of the leaf so you can see that
this protrusion
so the serration initiation is
associated with very high growth so you
have a lot a lot of growth cells are
very red they want to grow but this
first growth is very very short lasting
so it's only two days that the cells are
red and then the graph is going down and
the sort of no real good and stop
so what about car demeanor initiation of
the leaflet we see the same we have an
increase of growth the growth is fast
but the growth continued to be fast and
it continues it continues so basically
it's not a stop but it's like it
continued continued continued to
generate the leaflets that is big and
pronounced there's one more thing on
this slide that this interesting look at
the inhibition of girl phurba cyanosis
now so we have this cough as grow Ferber
tip here but we have also very strongly
a strong inhibition at the sinus
adjacent to the to the protrusion so
those tears are not growing those cells
are not growing basically helping to
make this indent here at the at the
decoration
but this inhibition of growth is again
very short lasting it's two days and
then it's over then you actually see
that this version that was not growing
is growing quickly so it's a river today
quickly in car demeanor no actually now
in CAD I mean that this inhibition is
maintained all over our observation
period after a eight days that some
cells that are not growing at all
there's this cool
there's one more interesting thing
regarding to this inhibition is that it
happens in different developmental
context so if you look at the first
science when you have the inhibition so
energy those cells that are inhibited
with grow are the sinuses here in
Arabidopsis and you make a lineage
tracing to see where they end up you
will see that actually they are very far
away from the midrib region here so they
actually the inhibition of growth
happens within the future blade already
so the blade of Araby daf is already
initiated here at this very early stages
in car demeanor if you do the same at
the same stage and you Mark toasters
that inhibited they actually directly
attached to the midriff so by basically
enabling the that full indentation that
goes all the way back to the midrib so
it suggests that at this stage the leaf
is not yet that the different regions
are not yet specified and so there is a
delay of differentiation what happens in
the in in cardamon a leaf so we wanted
to see if there is there any
differentiation that we can see the
delayed of differentiation in the cells
leaf so we used there's not magical
marker for differentiation unfortunately
there's no genetic marker so we used a
different bunch of characteristic like
growth rates cell sizes etc and one of
the thing that we can look at to to
infer about the state of the
differentiation of the cells is the cell
low penis so those the cells in
epidermis will start as a square like
sort of easel diametric cells and then
they will develop Lopes the pavement
cells so we have basically
quantified this aspect and you can see
that
at 7:00 already at five days of the
initiation you see you start to see the
pavement cells that start to develop
here and the whole leaf blade is sort of
like transferring to this differentiate
that stayed at this seven days in car
demeanor nothing happens after at six
days at seven days it starts and it's
still less advanced I mean our abilities
would even wonder later so we concluded
that the cell difference ages indeed
delay in car demeanor probably enabling
a huge outdoor table leaflets in the
species so for those key differences
that we observed would be the growth
during the initiation of the marginal
protrusion short lasting at the in
Arabidopsis long lasting her demeanor
and the timing of differentiation now
that two things the two key differences
between the two species so we wondered
if this is enough to actually explain
explain the so he's hypnotized that
actually if we remove this first thing
emerging a protrusion initiation we
should end up with not only the same
shapes but also with the same growth
patterns in the leaves if the growth
passes are conserved so to do that we
have used the NPD treatment so NP is a
drug that inhibits a polar oxygen
transport essential for the initiation
of the new marginal protrusions so if
you inhibit the NPA basically you will
have should have a smooth sleep and this
is what we have got as results for this
so here is the rabbit of sister Lyanna
Grove series of the leaf number eight or
adult life with that should have
serrations after and be a treatment and
you can see that this shape is smooth
star like the both actually speeches
have the same shape but don't only the
shape but also the groove patterns are
the same so you can see the busy patel
gradient of growth in both species you
can see also that the growth and
isotropy is the same so here you have a
heat map of growth and isotropy so
basically the Marcion is the cell the
more it's elongating and you can see
this all
of the petiole mid rivers along gating
in both species and the blade is more
homogeneous in growth in our abilities
in our abilities and in cardamon so then
we have similar growth patterns so
there's a sort of conserved default
growth in both species
so this default gavi consists of few
things at early stages we have a uniform
elongation of the tiny primordial later
on the basic beta gradient of growth
will be established within the leaf and
this this lazy Peter gradient of growth
will be followed by the tissue dependent
growth polarity so me tree patio will
elongate leaf blade will be just
expanding in all directions so is this
simple description sufficient to
describe what is happening in the leaf
this is very difficult to doing with
experimentation so we decided to do
modeling and basically we have we have
taken all the observations from from a
biological experiments from our life
imaging and we have implemented actually
Adam Green Ian's has implemented a model
to simulate this behaviour in silicon
computer so he has assumed that early
primaries is the Grove it's an isotropic
in the later primordium professor
isotropic at the midrib patio and this
isotropic in their live blade simple
assumptions then he also assumed that
there is a gradient of growth that is
established over time when prime under
is growing too big the bigger than than
some thresholds the differentiation
front will progress from the tip to the
base so he has implemented those simple
assumption in the model and this is what
he has got in this movie this is a
simulation with warmer regions growing
fast and blue Origin's growing slower
and you can see that basically using few
assumption you can generate a simple
smooth leaf phenotype in a computer
simulation and that was awesome
and this is how this compares to real
data so this is simulated a growth rate
in the cut to 3 mutants which lacks
serrations our belief margin and this is
a real data for growth and this is the
same for an isotropy so we can even see
small emerging and ISO trapeze up the
base that house or visible at the base
of the real relief that was really cool
and we are like oh my gosh
fantastic so but this is not the end of
the story and so we know how to do my
simple leaf with a simple assumptions so
how to do what do you know what do we
need to do to get serrations ok I
mentioned to you already had either
indirection introduction that in order
to get the protrusion at the margin you
need to have oxygen maximum forming and
inhibition of growth around the
protrusion probably due to the activity
of captive transcription factor we also
see that the growth of the protrusion of
the selection is very high so this is
from our data another thing that we
observe is that the growth is
repolarized so at locally whenever
oxygen maximum is created the growth
rate the growth orientations will be
pointing to this spot so it will be like
a local organizer of the tissue growth
that will start to grow towards the
small protrusion so what Adam has done
again is this basically he has
implemented all this information and he
has created a marginal model where
activity of pin card and oxygen leads to
accumulation of oxygen at specific spot
spot so at the beginning of the
initiation of the leaf and later the
initiation sites of the primordial and
so basically what he has done he has
taken this model is merging our model
and put it on top of the simple model I
have shown you before the simple model
that generates a simple leaf form and
now this margin is instructing the
tissue inside to repolarize and grow
local even faster so and if you do that
this
what you get basically so your primary
will be drawing homogeneously you have a
decrease of growth from the tip so the
establishing but you also have the
increase of growth of the tips of
serrations due to the accumulation of
the oxy and you will slowly actually
emerge progressive they'll believe that
actually has serrations on on the on the
on the margin and if you compare it to
real data again so this time I just show
you the growth and isotope is here you
can see that in simulated in simulation
the growth and ISO trapeze are sort of
matching quite nicely what we see in the
real data so there's alignment of growth
in the middle for example that they can
we can observe here we have this
radiating - an azeotrope is here but
also observed here and leaf blade is
growing more isotropic so this is more
like disorganized growth in both
orientations this is even better now
it's also cool again for us to see this
the real turn starts here so how do we
is this is there any way to transform a
rabid of cease leaf into kappamini like
leaf can we make compound leaf out of
ribbon OPS's let's see before we started
with his decided okay we are decided to
explore again computationally in
simulations what we will need to do to
the leaf to the protrusion at the margin
in order to make it out to transmit from
tiny serrations into the leaflets so
Adam has created a simulation of the
leaf margin on this so the simulation is
actually taking into account several
factors so there is a his implemented
simulations basic petal gradient of
Grove so you have a grow Grove at the
base and on the leaf is sort of flipped
you see so it's not so it's flip so we
have a Grove zone that so that whenever
the leaf is bigger this will drop the
graph will not occur anymore here you
will have a uh turning of the margin
that is associated with activity of
aux-in which promotes growth and
[ __ ] transcription factor that inhibits
draw so those are very simple
simulations in in the real life in the
real simulation that looks more or less
like this you will have growth growth
that will be very fast here there will
be zone where the growth will be
decreasing growth is actually not
anymore here and you will have oxygen
Maxima that will lead to the emergence
of those protrusions at the marks so
this is how the how this model will look
like in Arabidopsis wild-type so you can
see that it can reproduce the serrations
that we observe at the margin there
there's also very nice observation we
can see here that the serrations are not
symmetric and this is the true reality
in the leaf they are not symmetric sort
of like tilted towards toward the tip of
the leaf and we started to explore
different things so what he has done
first he decide ok what will happen if
we extend the growth domain so what we
do here is we have the same growth rate
but you just make it longer so it lasts
for longer yeah so it's sort of like
delaying differentiation somehow
enabling the leaf to grow longer
actually what happens here is that the
serrations are smooth so it's a sort of
opposite to what we see in academia so
this is not sufficient so what he has
also tried to do is to decrease the
growth so he decreased the longitudinal
growth so the Dom at that domain is the
same so the length is the same but the
growth is not high but it's just
decreased if you do that then you have
the slightly more pronounced protrusions
that emerge but still not so much later
on he decided to do ok I will combine
the two I extend the growth the
possibility the growth and I make this
growth slow so this is what happens you
have a quite pronounced protrusions now
and this is sort of car those two
effects are sort of the ones that you
could see if you delay differentiation
sort of like a meristematic tissue
growing slowly at the shoot apical
meristem not differentiating this is
going not so fast
okay so this was what seems to be needed
okay
unfortunately there is a gene that is
actually very important for the
different government of car Davina
a wild-type leaf compound leaf it's
called STM so should meristem less and
maybe you know this one it's a very
somatic gene that is important for to
maintain the meristem and normal are a
bit of sister Lyanna leaves it's not
expressed it's not there but in car
demeanor it's actually there it's
expressed it's very very very used
during development of the kappamini leaf
and if you remove this gene from car
demeanor compound if you have it you
have it simple okay so it's obviously
very important gene for development of
the compound leaf and place on
differentiation okay so what we decided
to do is to see what happens if we put
it to a rabid upses so here it's the
it's a wild-type Arabidopsis and just to
remind you the grow fat the protrusion
is short lasting so just two days and
then it stops drops down now what we do
is that we express STM promoter a CM
gene under leave specific promoter so we
force it to are a bit up this leaf and
what you can see here actually is that
now the serration does not stop growing
it continues from quite longer so
basically you actually do what happens
in Kedah meanie who puts their ability
to grow for longer to this leaf so you
would delay differentiation and by doing
differentiation and this is also visible
actually in different part of the leaf
because if you look at the distal part
of the leaf in a wild-type all groove is
gone here just tomate are still growing
in BLS STM pro plants transgenic line
you have the growth that still occurs so
basically it's it's starting from 2 to 3
days after initiation and then it's
mostly on the more lateral approximant
regions it's on this this this part is
not expressed so much here in revved up
system so basically now you you push the
regions that are going
more lateral parts and more distal parts
and you cannot actually quantify it well
because if you do the full lineage
tracing of the early leaf a new mark 20%
of cells at the tip of the leaf and you
look what happens to them at the end of
observation you still have about 20% of
the surface that is marked with this
with this the those discolor yeah so
there's no it started sort of relatively
a small contribution to the leaf surface
area if you do the same in the air a bit
of sister Lyanna BLS STM transgenic line
you do the same selection and you end up
by a region that is 2 times bigger which
actually confirms that you push growth
toward more distal regions and this is
actually matching what happens in Kerala
me Academy now because in calm demeanor
early leaf if you mark the 20% region it
will become about half of the leaf
surface in in total which is very cool
so we are pushing the leaf of our
abilities toward car demeanor but still
it's not sufficient yeah because here
you have a wild type with small
serrations this is the BLS STM this is
more complex but it's not compound so
something is missing still so what is
missing may be local growth repression
and there is a we have discovered in
2014 and published the paper about our
Zorc as a transcription factor that is
involved in leaf complexity in car
demeanor and it's a local graphic
wrestle we have shown that it's acting
locally at the signers to repress growth
and if you remove it from right side you
will get simplified leaf so we decided
to look at the growth in globally in our
in in this trance Jenny Kline so here we
have wild-type again it just as a
reminder have two serrations marked with
star and the region in between the
slower growing so this is like I would
say 3 to 400 percent growth under 24
hours is about 200 so 2 times slower
growth if we now express our CEO of
genomic version from cardamon in
Arabidopsis
region is actually this doses are not
going so fast anymore so basically it
leads to deeper indentation at the sinus
in between - Susur Asians leading to a
more low belief so this is more load
leaf compared to a wild-type if you
express our see of car demeanor but this
is again not a compound leaf obviously
not a compound leaf this is our
co-promoter its own promoter so it's
genomic region of the RCO Jim okay so
Adam came back with his model he has
taken this model where you extend growth
domain and decrease logic desire of
simulating SCM action actually and he
has added our co local graph oppression
at the base of those protrusions and
this is what's not just models suggest
what should happen with a very simple
geometric models of course this model is
not perfect so we wanted to check it and
we took this global factor this global
STM gene that delays differentiation we
took the local grove repressor that also
leads to more complex leaf and we
basically crossed them hoping that we'll
get something nice and actually this is
what we got yeah which is very cool we
have basically got a cool arab adopts
his compound leaf by expressing two
transcription factors inside arabic
obviously that are important for a
compound leaf development in car
demeanor as if you compare this double
transgenic line with wild-type academy
Nia you can see that it's sort of quite
similar you have now leaflets supported
by sessile like a petroleum similar to
car demeanor it's not identical but it's
quite nice so we probably managed to car
demonize
our abilities in this case and so my
conclusion from the story our talk is
are basically two by quantitative
modulation of growth and differentiation
you can you can produce large diversity
of the leaves so
have common programs that are
quantitatively modulated to generate
diversity and what is even more amazing
that is that by expressing two factors
two genes from a compound leaf into the
simple the insipidly background we can
generate complexity which is very very
very nice so what next I basically
conclude my talk now but I just want to
show you one slide to tell you what are
we going in the future for as well so in
my lab is now working among others
things about on the development of
homologous organs in the in in Arab
adoption so what do you need to make the
leaf versus pepper which are both
supposed to derive from the ancient leaf
like structures so we have doing the
time-lapse imaging of the first leaf for
example understand tenets of the settles
in in Arabidopsis so we are able now to
grow a look at the Grove up to nine days
and we are also interested in the
development of organs in more ancient
plants so don't ask where plants to
understand how they build this very
simple structure and also how this
compared to the vascular plants and I
would like to thank you thanks first of
all and the workouts I have presented
this Don skill in the Midwest and his
lab and the most important person to
highlight is Adam unions who has done
all the modeling part Richard Smith is
the developer of the software of
mammographies we are using all the time
and this is our group now in Montreux
and more precisely this is our group
here this my group actually and we are
closely collaborating with the lap of
unease routier who is a modeler and and
develop us also develop more for
graphics so this is our new environment
in montréal and we hope that we will get
something very nice very soon to show
you another seminar or another
conference now here's our funding so I
would like to thank you very
for your intention if you have any
questions through this question so I'll
link to it in real time as I asked it so
with the various modeling and then your
introduction of the various constructs
to alter complexity of the leaf so
nothing really happens to the midrib or
do you get a compression of growth or
I'm just wondering you know how do you
deal with the midrib and so solely
things this is actually very simplified
version of the talk because the paper is
pretty intensive and quite complex and
the pointing to the review is a very
good point because actually mid Reaper
also plays a very important role in this
change of the shape of the leaf because
what actually happens in in the BLS STM
transgenic line is not only that you
push the growth more external and right
lateral compartments of the leaf but you
also decrease a grow of growth in the
patio so basically you even more
amplified what happened so you decrease
this growth to make it even more in a
like sort of narrow at the base and this
effect is very important we can see it
that the le'me drip is actually growing
slower in inter dominant and in villa
cistern the inclined compared to what we
see in the wild a parapet OPS's and this
this sort of interaction between the
fast growing and soft Grove is actually
very important for the complexity of
organs anyway and so for example the
first leaf of arrábida abscess is not
producing any serrations even if there
are obscene Maxima happening at the
margin of this firstly and this is most
likely due to the very very fast growth
of the of the leaf especially in the
proximal distal orientation so basically
you could make it but you barely make it
and smooth it and this is also happening
mutants the leaf number eight of some
mutants you will not have any serrations
and this will be just it's not because
of the no patterning is not taking place
there is also maximum there is a small
bump very often what happens but it's
like it's it loses the the competition
will be longitudinal elongation of the
leaf so yes this is very important
actually part of making the compound
leaf so slightly complicated to explain
in a very short order
yeah thank you there are your question
if you said promoter just drive a
reporter gene how how where's that okay
I don't have this light here I guess but
if I go back to also using I go back to
the leaf here so this is a fully
developed leaf but just a simplification
it will be expressed at the sinuses and
around the around the initiating
protrusions so at the base that perhaps
the question wants to act and what makes
it do that we don't have yet we don't
know we don't know that we don't know
who is supporting this there at this
position but we know we know that there
is a homologue of this dream in our
abilities which is called LMI one gene
and LMI one is basically the same the
same genus it's produced very similar
protein you can swap element and our CEO
and dry them under our lease your
parameter they will do exactly the same
thing but the abdominal expression is
very different so if you'd express ulema
is expressed distally at the leaf margin
and end in the stipules and ours here is
at the base of the leaf
and not in the stables so yeah so we
don't know who is controlling the
expression of this but there is a very
specific evolutionary pressure to put
them in a specific position and those
gene actually this is exactly the same
gene drive so LMI or our CEO family dean
the is responsible for the development
of the tendrils in peace so it is
expressed in the memory distal regions
of the terminal leaflets of the of the
pea and not in the steeples you're like
in Arabidopsis and if you remove it you
get normal leaf so - I forgot the name
of the of the ginning in peace but yeah
it's the same thing basically they but
again just tweaked to be expressed
somewhere else and this same gene
actually inhibits the in the the the the
development of the scipios at the base
of the leaf so steep hills are
expressing LMI gene so achievement of
our CEO you remove LMI you have the
steepest transforming italy blades so
and p does not have any LMI expression
in the steeple and the stimulus likely
leave light basically Dominion yeah so
all of these serrations are sort of
hetero plastic traits associated with sa
change yes yes and so is there a similar
thermoplastic series in Carmina been
there for the competency to respond all
this yes yes exactly so the first leaf
of card I mean is simple
it expresses our Co but it does not do
anything probably because of different
dynamics of grow for the leek number one
which is very different from the number
ID which different from cow : leaf so
yes indeed and in calm demeanor you have
a first leaf that will be simple with
just sort of filming a leaf that over
time you have more and more pairs of the
lateral leaflets and then you will also
have the
small colonies that are sort of compound
with different forms compressed and
smaller I see yeah so so maybe you've
mentioned this already but this promoter
is active in all this so this promoter
before we started working with it it was
supposed to work five days after
initiation onwards but actually we have
checked the expression it starts like
two to a two days after initiation
so quite early maybe even earlier but we
haven't checked and the it's an
expression domain would be if I look if
I do it just on this one it will be like
more lateral domain and more proximal
domain so it will not be expressed at
the tip it will be relatively not
expressed in the in the middle so it's
it's there it's not a native expression
of the STM in card I mean it's not
exactly the same expression but by using
this specific promoter we managed to put
it in this position where it's needed or
the action and actually what I think is
that we could replace the STM gene with
something else that is meristematic like
a BP gene for example and you would
probably get the same function so it's
not so it's probably not the specificity
of this gene to do this it's just okay
we make the leaf grow slower and
differentiate slow a grower grow slower
for longer period of time and that will
make it more complex basically so that's
why we are talking about quantitative
not qualitative change that Lee drives
diversity of organs there so all the
same mechanics are just regular
operating there you just delayed
differentiation inhibit growth a little
bit more etc so tweaking this frame I
would
so you mentioned that that made me grow
slowly and with more energy shopping
yeah do we know what makes it do it so
we read we are not sure about it so what
we suppose happen it happens is that at
the it happens that in later at later
stages of development so I would say you
know you would have to go a little bit
just working I'm sorry okay if we go
back to this growth so here it is not it
is happening not at the very very early
stages is slightly later you can see it
very pronounced Li here so at this stage
the main vascular stranding on the main
mid vein of the leaf is already
developed so if you cannot make the grow
growth in the mid mid vein isotropic it
has to be an isotropic test it's sort of
fixed so what can happen is actually
that the veins that are developing
underneath in the internal issue they
fixes the growth but what we think is
that the patterning and the the the
polarization of the liver grove
polarization is regulated by oxen and
pins and cetera but locally and then
this mechanism is just take her or taken
over by other things vascular tissue or
just the isotropic graph in the middle
if light so the the polarizer is there
but it's probably not regulating all
over the leaf development it's just
locally sitting first axis but is taken
over by a scar tissue then the next axis
rlist initiated after sometime they fade
again and cetera cetera
this is likely scenario of course there
are other hypotheses on this that there
is a global Eliza but operates all over
the leaf but so here we show basically
by modeling my same experimentation that
it is not necessary to generate those
forms somehow the veins are really
really strange well so do you think
transport is disrupted and so in line
with that
do you have differences in the frequency
of convergence points like I eat
serrations so yeah so there is one point
one point answering the second question
is there a difference in D in the amount
of the convergent points in between wild
type r of the option B LSST M yes indeed
and you can happen normally in
Arabidopsis you have busy pet or
gradient of renunciation of the of the
serrations so they will appear one after
another in the SD MPLS STM you can have
already like sort of hijacked sometimes
you will have additional protrusions
emerging in more distal regions or in
between you read the pin but you
basically need non differentiated tissue
in wild-type Arabidopsis you will never
have a session that appears above the
first one because those cells the
marginal cells already elongated and
they are just loo they lose a capacity
to initiate any protrusion in BLS STM
those cells actually dividing so
sometimes you have a region with small
meristematic cells that will have
expression of pin and they will leap for
initiation of additional protrusions is
it so a system is just that you have the
growth potential to make restoration or
is it that you actually have more
convergence you have both you have a
leave that you can have a more
convergence point but you have also put
in longer potential for generation of
those guys and this pls STM I don't know
if we can have it here if we come back
one slide before you see it is not they
have additional protrusions at the at
the leaf lobes yeah so those are exactly
does this is what I'm talking about you
can see them here you can see it here
this was the first one initiated but
there is a second one coming here so
they have both potential to do both
things and if you come back to the first
question it is not identical but this
leaf form is still not in Antigua and
this size of the leaf is not identical
so the card I mean I will leave will be
sorry our abilities will be like
standard are a bit of Cisco demeanor
will be standard card Amina so there is
some other things and actually
you probably make the compound leaf but
you freezes you freezes the development
of this leaf a slightly area but because
those serrations here what happens they
also are and landed here because you see
those small indents here those are
serrations but they are sort of hidden
and very tiny they are basically this
terminal leaf that grows for longer and
is filling up the space in between so
this is smaller this is bigger there's
something else but it's important that
makes it slightly different still yeah
it's compound both have a compound but
not identical and the same happens here
you know still it's sessile I sorry like
a with a patio patio Lilu on both but
this is much more pronounced this one
there's one vein there's maybe two veins
coming no it's not identical it's very
pretty close I think what is happening
here is that you have other factors that
will make this leaf differentiate first
faster so they does not have enough time
to grow enough beak to fill out those
spaces maybe even to generate some this
this modification of the of the basket
but in vascular tissue it can be also
Pina it's it's not exactly the same
context there because leaf of
Arabidopsis if you take for example leaf
number one it starts to differentiate at
two days of the initiation you have some
marginal cells that a tiny prime odium
they will be already there and they will
never divide anymore so which is very
amazing because you look at some tiny
tiny tiny thing that you're supposed to
be meristematic but it's not are not yet
not not anymore in some cities in some
some cells yeah so from two days after
initiation you will trace lineage for
some marginal cells and they will be
there yeah little like it's like
instable so well giant cells will also
start quite early
maybe not so early like in the leaf but
but still like three four days of the
Annunciation
[Applause]
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu